ever happens perhaps trying to set a
screen guys coming off the curl and he
can post up
gordon to inbound fournier trying to
fight through screens he's got it
fournier
out near half court ten seconds
remaining bullock guarding him gibson
picks it up ball deflected and stolen by
bog
reggie bullock with the steal burke's
dribbling gets away from bunchovich
and the knicks will win it what a finish
who got caught with the hell ball
situation redeems himself with a big
steal
and the knicks win their fourth straight
of the garden
defense defense redemption time for
bullock
you know his birthday was a few days ago
folks
so he's celebrating now feeling the love
of his teammates with that steal
in the first game this season he came
off the bench he had 20 points
he hit six three-pointers but he saves
the most important and the biggest play
for last
as he comes up with a steal in the final
possession
and fournier had been the catalyst for
the magic had 10 points in the quarter
and you see the illavadz jump he leaped
in the air and
bullock able to come up with the steal
and nick's able to steal the deal
and clyde a key on that bullock fights
over the screen
he doesn't get caught on a big screen by
the seven foot
boochovich and the knicks celebrating so
many different knicks
with some big performances and big plays
and reggie bullock with a big steal to
go along with 20 points alec burks had
21. r.j barrett had 17 points
julius randle 17 of